When my first guest had
her first breakthrough at age ten
she already knew
she'd be a superstar.
Now she's 19, and all has gone
to plan. Welcome, Zara Larsson.
Thank you so much.
Can you remember, before you were
famous, the first song you learned?
I'm sure it was a Carola song,
I think, actually...
-Or maybe Whitney Houston.
-Can you sing like Carola?
If I can do impression of Carola?
Oh, it was that good? Thank you!
-It's fantastic.
-Thank you so much.
Carola is awesome,
Whitney Houston is awesome.
Your rise to fame has been meteoric,
seeing as you're only 19.
-But you've been around a long time.
-I have.
You're seen on one of the biggest
shows on TV in the US right now.
You got to open the Euro 2016.
Now you're releasing a new album.
Do you still control your own time?
Is it easy to lose control
of your time?
It's a bit like that, but that's
because I have a tight schedule.
I have very little downtime,
which is a good thing.
I'm very busy, I do a lot of things,
a lot of fun stuff.
I love what I do, but I'm the type
of person who is totally unaware.
Yesterday I was saying to my mom:
"I've got something tomorrow, right?"
And well, here I am, today.
But I really don't know what
I've got scheduled, and I love it.
-So you want it that way?
-Yes.
-How far ahead do you think?
-Two days, tops.
You make a lot of money.
Do you manage it?
No.
OK... Who is in charge of it?
-Mommy and Daddy.
-That's good.
They keep an eye on it,
and they wouldn't steal from me.
I'll probably be back here in
20 years and go, "Well, darn it..."
No, they would never do that.
Do you get like a fixed allowance?
Well, last night I called my mom
to ask for 200 kronor for the movies.
But I mean, I still live at home,
I don't pay any bills.
I don't have a car,
not even have my license.
I have no expenses.
I only spend money on fun stuff.
If I had access to all the money,
there would be a lot of fun stuff.
I'd be like...
Have you bought anything expensive
that you've felt good about?
Well, yesterday, actually,
or the day before that...
I bought an apartment
for my grandmother.
-That's great.
-Well, you know, stuff like that.
That, to me, feels worth it.
So do you call your mom and say,
"I need money for an apartment?"
No, it's all my mom. She asked me
if I thought we should do it.
And I said yes, of course Grandma
should have a little place.
-Has Grandma moved in yet?
-No, it's a new build. Next year.
She'll be close to my cousins,
my sister...
Right now she's all alone
in my father's hometown.
I think this will be great for her.
-Was she happy to get it?
-Very.
-I bet.
-I bet she was, too.
I just hope she stays alive
long enough to move in.
It would be a real shame otherwise.
You are 19, so you could have
your driver's license.
-But you don't?
-No.
-Would you be a good driver?
-I know what you're getting at.
I'm getting at the fact that
you have some experience driving.
Some, yes.
I've got a license to drive a moped.
Explain this to me,
because I'm not from Sweden.
-Only in Sweden do they have this...
-Really?
-You don't have mopeds in Norway?
-Yes...
Yes, we do.
Yes, people do have mopeds.
If you're too scared
to ride a motorcycle.
But not this weird quadricycle,
which looks like a car...
It does look like a car,
but the max speed is 30 mph.
So I can go all over Stockholm,
as long as it's not a highway.
And how's that working out for you?
So well that the manufacturer
withdrew their endorsement.
I've been in a few accidents,
let's put it that way.
You're more like a serial offender.
That's how you see it?
I suppose, yes.
Those of you who are from
Stockholm know the Klara tunnel.
-From City to the south...
-Lots of heavy traffic.
And as with most roads,
traffic flows both ways.
But one tunnel goes one way only,
the other tunnel goes the other only.
So when you enter the tunnel,
that's it.
And I of course managed
to enter the wrong tunnel.
And this was... Let me explain!
This was late on a Tuesday night,
there were no cars around.
And I had had my license for one day.
I was so happy,
driving my little car.
I was heading home,
but was unsure where I was going.
So I was like,
"Right or left? Right or left?"
And there's a huge sign
that says, "Right".
But I was like, "You know what?
Left feels right to me."
-Well, you must listen to your gut.
-So I enter the tunnel.
I'm driving in the right lane,
because I know my stuff.
Then an oncoming car
has to swerve and honks at me.
And I'm like, "What the hell
are you doing in my lane?"
Then another car comes,
and we crash into each other.
That's when I realize
I'm in the wrong tunnel.
But everyone was fine.
It could have been so much worse.
I think the backseat is a great idea.
-I'm sure your parents agree.
-Yeah...
I know you come from a home
where debate is encouraged.
You've debated a lot, especially
with your dad, who's in the military.
I read somewhere
you and your dad debate for hours.
-Definitely.
-What do you discuss?
I mean, in my family, you know...
I talk a lot - I really do.
But I've got absolutely nothing
on my father. He has no off switch.
We have a lot of discussions.
But I can ask my dad a simple
question and get a whole lecture.
He is very knowledgeable.
Is he what feminists
like to call a "mansplainer"?
Tell me about it! So many times
I've had to say, "Stop mansplaining!"
A simple question can lead
to a 15-minute monologue.
But he's amazing
and incredibly knowledgeable.
He's probably the reason
I'm so interested in social issues.
I want to learn about
our political environment.
We talk a lot about, well,
feminism is a huge issue for me.
So that's great,
to have been brought up like that.
You've been very outspoken
about your feminist views.
And you have a very political voice,
in addition to your singing voice.
-And especially on social media.
-Yes.
You tweet roughly, if not more,
then at least on a par with Trump.
-Yeah... I'm up there.
-It does get to be a lot.
Do you ever feel...regret?
-Do I what?
-Do you regret any of your tweets?
Like, "I was too harsh there."
There was this one thing
that I had to delete.
And it was after I saw the first
"50 Shades of Grey" movie.
In my personal opinion - it's not my
type of movie - I thought it sucked.
So I tweeted, "If you like this,
go here" - and linked to Pornhub.
-Which is...
-But that's the only thing!
Which is one of many pornographic
sites online. There are more.
Just to explain what it is.
-I should explain it?
-No! I've explained it. No more!
-Please, no more about that!
-OK. I personally didn't regret it.
But the label was like, "You're great
on Twitter, say whatever you want."
"But stuff like that,
maybe it's unnecessary?"
But when you say things like,
"I hate men" - you get into fights.
-I get into fights.
-Lots of grumpy men out there.
And you hear from some them.
But you don't mean them personally?
Or maybe sometimes you do,
but do you mean all men or...?
-Are you offended now?
-No, I'm unoffendable.
Just kidding! Of course I don't mean
all men, but this debate is boring.
I just mean that macho culture
and men in general, in groups...
...are scary, unpleasant,
and just annoying.
Exactly.
And what happens when you...
When you voice an opinion like that,
you get attacked by "trolls" online.
-Absolutely.
-You get a lot of hate.
-Do you read it?
-To a certain extent.
I think the more I am online,
just like all kids today...
...the more I learn to kind of...
On Twitter, there are
a lot of "eggs" for profile pictures.
Right, the ones that are...
Eggs are usually private profiles
with zero followers.
-They're anonymous?
-Exactly, very anonymous.
The ones who hide behind that
are those who write the worst stuff.
It's easier to not be affected
by them, because it feels...
You know? It doesn't feel real.
I'd have tweeted just as much or even
more, if I didn't have my followers.
Like I said, I grew up in a very
debate-friendly environment.
That's just what I'm like.
I want to voice my opinion.
I want to be heard and seen,
I want people to listen to me!
So when you debate
and you go, for example...
"I hate all men."
Does your dad agree?
He understands exactly what I mean.
To get back to this irrelevant topic.
When I say "all men," my dad isn't
offended, nor are my guy friends.
I have men in my life
that I love and admire.
But it's constantly this...
"Hey, not all men!" Yeah, we know!
But if you're not a rapist,
or a wife beater, or a bully...
If that's not you, then don't
get offended by it. That's all.
You know what I mean?
We need to understand
what privileges we have.
I truly believe
that there are privileges.
You're very privileged if you happen
to be white, male, rich, cis.
So you need to check yours.
What are my privileges?
I'm cis-gendered, with a body
that conforms to ideals...
I'm straight, I'm white...
I need to be able to see that.
-Thank you so much for being here.
-Thank you!